everything's expensive in New York I
want to buy new glasses eyeglasses went
to the boutique place I go how much
these glasses the guy said they're a
thousand dollars
I was like oh that's kind of expensive
he's like well think of it this way
you'll have them for three years
it's like a dollar a day
well when you put it that way it sounds
more expensive
if I asked you how much these glasses
were and he said you have to give me a
dollar a day every day for three years
I'd be like wow that is a pricey pair of
glasses
I'm doing the math in my head I'd say
that's roughly one thousand dollars
why don't I take a thousand dollars by
two pairs of 200 glasses and also a
round trip ticket to Barcelona
foreign